I am here in Japan the Prime Minister
seven Summit but I couldn't miss this
opportunity to come here and thank all
of you the brilliant businesses who have
together made the relationship between
our two countries the strongest it has
ever been
and we're better to do that than this
stunning exhibition incredible British
design by the heatherwick studio
overlooking the dynamic and iconic city
of Tokyo the perfect backdrop to
celebrate the incredibly exciting
relationship between the United Kingdom
and Japan
Mrs Mori thank you for your hospitality
congratulations on this exhibition and
also your fantastic new azabudai Hills
development we feel very honored to be
here thank you
[Applause]
now businesses from our two countries
have a long proud history of partnership
from the trains that we ride to the cars
that we drive and the drinks that we
enjoy
UK and Japanese firms work together
every single day to power each other's
economies and today we're going even
further I'm delighted to announce new
investment commitments worth nearly 18
billion pounds this is a huge vote of
confidence in the UK economy it will
create hundreds of good well-paid jobs
with significantly more to come as these
projects get underway
reinforcing our shared strengths in
science technology and clean energy and
above all growing our economy one of my
five priorities for the UK
and let me just take a moment to thank
some of the incredible businesses making
that happen
marubeni are investing 10 billion pounds
in clean energy over the next 10 years
Sumitomo Corporation 4 billion pounds in
offshore wind and Sumitomo electric our
manufacturing offshore wind cables in
Scotland and all of these companies are
bringing to life the new UK Japan
renewable energy partnership announced
today by our two governments and that's
not all
and Mitsubishi estate have an
infrastructure pipeline worth three and
a half billion pounds and Toshiba are
expanding their Cutting Edge Cambridge
laboratory and of course Nissan continue
to be at the heart of our automotive
industry
and I'm also delighted that UK companies
are in demand here in Japan too
take octopus energy over the next few
years they will invest one and a half
billion pounds in this region
all mock McDonald building a
state-of-the-art offshore Wind Farm
powering nearly two hundred thousand
Japanese homes and Leonardo will export
over 150 million pounds of their
world-class helicopters to Japan
now these Partnerships will create
prosperity in both our countries
so I'm sure you will join me in saying
to all those businesses and all of those
helping to strengthen the economic
partnership between our two countries
thank you
[Applause]
but while I have you all here I wanted
to briefly Bang the Drum for Britain and
give you three quick reasons why the
United Kingdom is right now one of the
most exciting destinations in the world
for Japanese businesses
first our strong secure trade lengths
the UK is the only European country to
join the cptpp
that is a huge opportunity the UK will
stand with Japan to uphold the cptpp's
high standards and maximize the benefits
for our businesses from this Dynamic and
fast-growing free trade block and let me
personally thank Japan and Minister goto
for your support in our accession
[Applause]
secondly the United Kingdom is
unambiguously pro-investment the lowest
rate of corporation tax of any G7
country
one of the most generous Capital
allowances regimes in the oecd and a
smart agile approach to regulation
and thirdly just like Japan the United
Kingdom is an island of innovation
we have the funding with 20 billion
pounds of public investment in research
and development we have the people with
a highly skilled Workforce we have the
ideas with some of the world's best
universities and we have the businesses
we've created over 160 technology
unicorns behind only the United States
and China
so Innovation investment and open trade
those are the ingredients that will take
the UK Japan relationship even further
and I hope to host many of you in person
in the United Kingdom later this year
for our next Global investment Summit
so let me just close by saying thank you
when I look around this room and see so
many brilliant businesses innovators and
entrepreneurs
I feel so proud of what we've achieved
but also so excited about what's still
to come the opportunity for us all is
incredible
so let's go and seize it together
arigato
[Applause]